- I think, like for a second
episode, it's getting better.
All right, it's...
What are you doing?
I don't get it.
- That, you can't walk on that.
- What?
- You telling me you have no problem
walking on that flimsy thing?
Does that look safe to you?
- Yeah, it looks perfectly fine.
- Picture this.
So you're walking along,
minding your own business,
bam, out of nowhere a sidewalk
grate is right in your path.
You think to yourself,
okay, if it was unsafe
I'd probably hear more about
people falling in, right?
So you take that step.
You take a leap of faith.
One step, you're good.
You see, no problem.
But when you land that second foot,
you hear strain in the middle.
It breaks its hold and you plummet,
never to be seen or heard from again.
- That's literally never
crossed my mind once.
- You are crazy.
All right, you gotta know this one.
Basements.
- You're afraid of basements now?
- I'm not afraid of basements,
what do you think I am.
I'm talking about the stair scenario.
- You gave it a name.
- Any time you head down to the basement,
there's that unavoidable feeling of fear
that creeps back up on you
when you head up the stairs.
You hear a noise; your
heart starts racing.
Each step, each creak you feel
like something's approaching.
You start having this
conversation with yourself, right?
You're like, chill out, man, you're fine.
But the more you try to make light of it,
the more you feel like you're
some horror movie cliche.
You look back, maybe you've
forgotten to turn the light off.
Shit.
You flick the light
off as fast as you can,
running up those stairs,
never looking back.
You start leaping,
jumping, skipping steps,
you just barely make it up to that door
and then slam it on whatever
godforsaken creature
is locked down there,
waiting for that one day
that one time when you're not fast enough.
All right, everybody knows
about the foot dangle.
Dude, you're telling me
you've never heard about the--
- Just tell me what it is.
- So when you're sitting on your bed
and you're flicking through
Instagram or whatever,
and then you think back
to all those movies
that terrified you as a kid.
Where there's something under the bed,
and the person, completely
unaware that this demonic thing
is inching closer and closer.
And you think to yourself, that's crazy.
But you know what, you still
get your feet out of there,
up on the bed, and even though you know
it's totally irrational, you feel better.
Dude, you've never felt
that way before? Come on.
- I think you've seen way
too many scary movies.
- Have you ever been sitting on the toilet
and you think to yourself,
what if something just crawled
up right now, and just--
There doing your business,
and you start to think to yourself,
do we really know what's
going on in this plumbing?
I mean, sewers breed
all kinds of crazy shit,
rats, snakes, alligators.
You start to tense up a bit,
which of course doesn't help
with your current situation.
What the hell was that noise?
You force yourself to look down there.
Phew, nothing, deep breath.
Wait a second, you jump
off the toilet just in time
to avoid the mutant snake
monster hungry for your--
- I get it, I get it.
- Dude, this stuff happens, man.
- Does it.
- I'm serious.